prochaine le chantage au nucléaire de la
corée du nord la crise entre pyongyang
et washington s'aggrave la corée du nord
a annoncé son retrait immédiat du traité
de non prolifération nucléaire une
décision en forme de provocation qui a
entraîné la condamnation immédiate de la
communauté internationale
julien colombani
le plomb du speaker de la télévision
nord-coréenne et martial car le
communiqué qu'il y est un défi lancé par
son gouvernement au monde entier nous ne
pouvons plus être liée par le traité de
non prolifération nucléaire le
gouvernement de la république
démocratique de corée du nord protège sa
souveraineté et son droit d'exister dans
la dignité les coréens du nord assurent
qu'ils n'ont pas l'intention de produire
des armes nucléaires mais aujourd'hui en
sortant du traité il s'en donne le droit
d'un bout à l'autre de la planète les
réactions ne se sont pas fait attendre
condamnation unanime la france condamne
cette décision la corée du nord doit
comprendre qu'elle n'a pas d'autre voie
que de renoncer à son programme
nucléaire militaire
développé en contradiction avec ses
engagements et le droit international
un ex pas la décision nord coréenne
n'est pas surprenant et mais elle
constitue une grave préoccupation pour
ses voisins comme sur l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale
des discussions des officiels sont en
cours entre américains et nord-coréens
car washington reste ouvert à une
reprise du dialogue à une reprise du
marchandage plus tôt avec ce pays
dernier régime stalinien de la planète
qui pourrait bien détenir deux ou trois
bombes nucléaires
elle ce soir l'ambassadeur nord-coréen à
l'onu a averti que pyong yang considéré
toutes sanctions économiques prises par
le conseil de sécurité comme une
déclaration de guerre